If you're not here, please raise your hand.
In Montgomery County, Maryland, long
one of the nation's most admired school
systems, huge numbers of high schoolers
are graduating despite repeatedly
skipping required classes. In 2018, out of
11,000 graduates, 1,800 had 20 or more
unexcused absences — in one class! During
the single 90-day semester! Schools need
to rethink how they're approaching
required seat time, but that can't mean
simply letting students skip school. Some
students do have legitimate trouble
getting to campus, but the same
administrators who tell teachers they
won't tolerate failure
can't excuse rampant absenteeism and
then expect teachers to teach students
who aren't there! There are many
incentives to get high schoolers that
diploma. District and state officials
want rising graduation rates, families
want kids to graduate, and teachers don't
want to be seen as troublemakers. So be
wary: If a close look revealed this
craziness in one of the nation's most
respected school districts, there's a
good chance it's an issue in your local schools too.
Should high schools have an
attendance requirement for graduation?
Let us know in our poll. Also, let us know
what other topics you'd like our
scholars to cover in 60 seconds, and be
sure to like and subscribe for more
research and videos from AEI.